I'd be the first to admit that we went
down this road really at the beginning
for the pure joy of taking on a
challenge that was largely thought to be
impossible
there was no textbook on how to go and
do this I'm Richard browning I am
founder and chief test pilot for gravity
and we build thousand horsepower jet
engine flying suits for the last few
years
browning and his team have tested every
possible design and configuration they
could come up with all in an effort to
make this a reality the origins of the
concept were all around some of the
inspiration from my early life I used to
fly model gliders and model aircraft my
father he was an aeronautical engineer
his father was a pilot so I guess it was
in the blood but fulfilling his dream of
flying required real physical demands
too I spent some time in the Royal
Marines Reserve and the time in the
military and all the sports I pursued
after that taught me a lot about the
capability of the human mind and body
I'm no great athlete but I did learn a
lot about how if you focus the human
form on a challenge whether you want to
be an ice skater or a gymnast or
whatever it is amazing how this machine
can be adapted I got to the point with
this calisthenics bodyweight training
where I could support my own weight in a
number of different kind of unusual
positions like flags for instance and I
thought well if you just replace that
hard structure that I'm holding onto
with actually a form of thrust
I can hold my body in any number of
different kind of fly positions so as
ludicrous as that sounded I thought well
let's just go and experiment with it
first he needed to figure out how to
stay suspended in the air the form of
thrust I landed on was gas turbines gas
turbines are notorious for being very
small form factors extremely aggressive
one gas turbine weighs five pounds and
puts out about 50 pounds of thrust so in
browning started testing different
components and variations and so have
experimented one we went to two and then
went to four and it was getting
increasingly compelling but things
didn't always go quite so smoothly
through lots and lots of trial and error
and constantly failing to be honest then
learning all the time from those safe
bales we got to a point where we managed
to achieve a flight and that was two
engines on each arm and he had engine on
each leg but there were basic problems
at every stage starting with the
decision to have engines on each leg
there's a number of interesting
challenges with that model the problems
included the engines being only three or
four inches off the ground in terms of
the exhaust thrust the violence of air
coming out of those engines at about a
thousand miles an hour and hitting even
concrete you could see a smooth concrete
surface would start to become pitted
from the sheer violence of that air and
yet as you move them away the the
violence of velocity drops off there was
also a challenge with having the engines
on the legs in that if you happen to
vector your arm engines anywhere near
the intakes of the lower engine we
realized that you're in in ducted air is
going in and that would then spike the
exhaust temperature you could see a
little puff of Sparks and the engine
would just shut down so that was another
good reason for not having engines down
there and finally there's a strange
human behavior we learned which is that
when your feet feel the ground and
Earth's left them they they almost want
to pedal and Scrabble around looking for
where that surface is that's not helpful
when you've got 50 pounds of thrust
coming off your leg and those problems
led to the solution of actually moving
those engines slowly up the body and
then consolidating them into one and
essentially that created a skirt all at
the same altitude in the body which can
be likened to the three legs of a tripod
there's thrust coming out of each arm
and then essentially a third leg coming
out of the back of your body which
provides that uncanny stability and
that's how we learn to fly I can set me
through what the components are so
you've essentially got an arm mount that
your arm goes inside that aluminium 3d
printed tube you've got a micro gas
turbine on each side and you've got the
same on the other side obviously and
round the back and there's one more
engine which is roughly the power of
these two together the front here you've
got a lot of the electronic control
systems and the batteries which aren't
plugged in here those batteries actually
run the starter motors and the glow
plugs and then on the sides you've got a
couple of fuel bladders we've also got a
helmet but it's especially lightweight
one and the extra addition to it is a
heads-up display system so inside there
you can see the the lenses which
actually paint over my vision the fuel
and engine data that data gets to the
lenses via this little device that takes
a wireless feed from the suit that shows
me everything to do with the engines and
everything to do everything to do with
the fuel to give you an idea as to how
close we are to running out of fuel for
instance last year browning set the
world speed record for a body controlled
jet suit clocking in at 32 miles per
hour
he says the suit can actually fly much
faster and higher than they've ever
attempted but for now they're playing it
safe that's because even at lower speeds
and altitudes there are still risks the
fuel is either diesel or jet fuel
they're fundamentally the same fuels
Jeff will sound scary but it's the same
kind of stuff
the diesel it's actually not prone to
forming vapor clouds it's not really
explosive in fact you're really hard
push to even ignite it and even if it
did burn in an uncontrolled way you've
certainly got probably 1015 seconds
before it becomes a big fire every
single time we fly we have fire
extinguishers around the place in two
years of doing this we've never used a
fire extinction
worried but I have a respect for the
fire out aspect of this the heat aspect
of it it's funny but if you get a
hairdryer and you press it against your
head you're gonna burn your head hold it
like two feet away and it's cold the
specific heat capacity of air is so poor
that actually the heat dissipates really
quickly and I've even swiped those
engines across my leg with with this you
know heavy cotton flight trousers on all
it did is just slightly singe the very
top surface of the fabric it didn't do
anything
so from a heat and fire point of view
it's really not a significant concern we
but we managed it he's more concerned
with Falls and collisions it's akin to
riding a sports motorbike
if you if you've done that eighteen
hundred miles an hour around small
twisty roads and come off that it's
gonna hurt if I'm ten feet above the
ground and got an engine failure I
simply go downwards there is no scenario
where our system can suddenly in an
uncontrolled way gain height or shoot
off to one side you simply drop which is
not a good thing but we've always got to
allow for the potential for extremely
unlikely mechanical failure of one of
the engines and then in which case you
do you do fall that's why we keep the
height fairly limited speed wise we can
easily do 35 miles an hour so we've come
quite a bit quicker in testing but again
for most of what we do by the time
you've done 35 miles an hour you've gone
a long way away from probably the
audience or the area you're flying so by
then you're coming back again we push
the limits a little bit more over water
because that's a bit more forgiving if
you could if you fell in it so brownies
jet suit is no longer just a pipe dream
but what exactly is it for they recently
started custom designing and selling
them but at a price tag of about four
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
suit it's safe to say it'll be out of
reach for most but that could change as
we improve the efficiency of the ease of
use then there is the potential for I
don't want to see mass transit straight
away but but we have developed something
that allows you to move human beings
around in a in a completely
unprecedented way one of the biggest
challenges for bringing down cost
designing suits that are more fuel
efficient this model currently burns
about a gallon of fuel a minute that's
one of the reasons they're working on an
electric version and a set of wings that
when deployed mid-flight would generate
lift more efficiently they're also
hoping some competition went spur
innovation throughout history when when
two human beings have said I think
mine's Boston the newest that does push
the envelope so next year 2019 we are
building out a race series for this yes
a racing series think Formula One but
with the jet suits
we've already had several pilots flying
the record so far is five minutes five
minutes of airtime so we can have a
bunch of young guys and girls go and
actually racing thousand horsepower jet
suits over water to keep it safe but
doing something that only people have
seen before really in a Marvel film and
that is gonna push the boundaries like
nothing
I think for the immediate future it'll
be entertainment it'll be inspiring
people and it'll be really fueling the
journey on to creating a revolution in
human transport